well what we know is that the police
were called at 9 35 PM last night after
reports of a crowd trying to force their
way into the auto Academy in Brixton
London Ambulance Service also attended
so did the London fire brigade now eight
people were treated four of them are
still in hospital in a critical
condition two people with lighter
injuries were treated right here now as
you can see here behind me The Cordon
still in place police officers still on
scene investigation is underway but no
one has been arrested yet now the Met
police have released a statement about
this incident the statement is by the
Met police gold command Ade Adele Khan
and it says this is an extremely
upsetting incident which has left four
people critically ill in hospital my
thoughts and prayers are with them and
their families it goes on to say a
police investigation has been launched
and it will be as thorough and as
forensic as necessary to establish
exactly what happened last tonight
officers are remaining in the area to
provide reassurance to the local
community in and around Brixton if you
have any information or concerns please
speak with them now there's a number of
social media videos circulating they
show a large number of people in front
of the venue some of them trying to
force their way in some of them
confronting the police officers there's
also a side street with what looks like
packed with hundreds and hundreds of
people now the artist who had his
performance here Nigerian artist called
a shark here he tweeted in hours before
the concert that it was sold out now
it's unclear if people who turned up
here thought that they could get tickets
on the night or they were hoping to get
a glimpse of him nonetheless four people
critically ill in hospital and an
incident where investigation is underway